hallo und herzlich willkommen zum 30
gemeinsamen workout ja ihr habt richtig
gehört ich war auch erstaunt wie immer
das anstatt 30 manchmal bereits
gemeinsam trainiert und heute zum 30
ein besonderes highlight für euch die
world challenge wir bereiten das vor so
trainiert der einsatz zur tat und ihr
könnt mit trainieren zuhause herunter
gebrochen so dass ihr das auch gut
mitmachen können wir das ist der gerne
das bin ich der beta und unser
spezialgast die frau gefreite céline
dion eine badminton spielerin die mit 16
die jüngste staatsmeisterin österreichs
war und jetzt da mitten in einer
vorbereitungs drinnen steht für
europameisterschaften und
weltmeisterschaften mit natürlich dem
gros gesteckten fernziel der olympischen
spiele aber am besten ist das stößt ihr
ganz gut selbst vor ich bin wie gesagt
und ich spezialisiert mich auf
damendoppel und mixed doppel seit
letztem jahr bin ich im bundesheer als
herr sportlerin angestellt und konnte
somit meine leidenschaft zum beruf
machen
dankeschön und wenn ihr jetzt fragt zu
hause was hat jetzt eine badminton
spielerin mit familie cherry fitness zu
tun hat kennt jetzt im ersten satz sagen
nicht viel
ja aber genau um das gehts wir wollen
euch einfach auch zeigen dass auch ihr
zuhause jederzeit außer training machen
können mitmachen können mit einfachen
hilfsmitteln einfach belasten könnte und
entsprechend dadurch körperlich fit
werden könnte und natürlich dass die
großen startvorteil als
leistungssportlerin bist du vielleicht
nicht in der military fitness so im
training drinnen aber generell natürlich
topfit oder gesetzt verletzungen gehabt
oder zum glück nicht muss man ihr holz
klopfen
also alles alles gut bitte schauen uns
jetzt wieder an
am besten ist wir starten mit einem
aufwärmprogramm weil die challenge an
sich wird dann sehr anstrengend und ihr
werdet es danke mitkriegen das heißt wir
müssen entsprechend intensiv aufwärmen
und fahren wir gerne an mitlaufen am
stand geht schon los
also für euch ganz kurz zu hause was ist
die world challenge ja das ist ein
wettkampf wo man beginnt mit einer meile
laufen
das waren ungefähr 1600 meter danach
geht's hinein
100 g zucker 200 liegestütze 300
kniebeugen und danach wieder eine weile
laufen und dass so rasch wie möglich
wer jetzt denkt dass sie erzählt wie sie
am ausprobieren ja drauf kommt man es
ist als andere wie sie und so wie wir
euch das jetzt weiter präsentieren
werden ist es so wie ihr euch darauf
vorbereiten könnt solltet ihr die
herausforderung annehmen wollen ok haben
wir kurz auslagern arme kreisen vorwärts
[Applaus]
und rückwärts kreisen
wie viele stunden trainierst du
geschätzt in der woche zwischen 5 und 23
25 und 30 stunden trainiert die serie
heute heute eine halbe stunde
militärisch fitness kannst am
trainingsplan eintragen zeigen und ich
bin gespannt wie es dann danach auch
geht ok gegen gleich angreifen einmal
vor einmal zurück und richtung wechseln
und dann laufen wir wieder anstand kennt
ja immer wieder mal anfassen am knie
hebel auf das dazu mit eine nehmen und
vor sehr gefragt in welcher zeit man
diesen werve diesem erstellen erledigen
kann also die komplette challenge ist
der weitere kommt irgendwo im bereich
von plus minus bei 25 minuten und das
ist schon wichtig weil schnell also da
gibt es überhaupt keine pause für den
anfänger ist einmal glaube ich schon mal
recht cool wäre wenn man sagt man schon
mal die hälfte oder und irgendwann das
fernziel das ganze was war so im
mittelfeld angesiedelt das ist wie
gesagt richtig große herausforderung für
100g zu schaffen so eine durchgehend
punkten das funktioniert nicht mit
kurzen pausen zwischen drinnen die
gestaltet man selbst ja aber 100 gibt
sich an einem stück zu machen das ist
schon eine richtige herausforderung also
nicht nur für uns da passt und game
einen schritt weiter gehen wir ins
kreisen der hüfte das handy in die hüfte
hinein und das becken kreisen
hüftkreisen
richtung wechseln und ganz wichtig wenn
ihr so intensive workshops vor ich hab's
wir haben sich wirklichkeit aufbereitet
den körper vor auf die belastung die
kommt dann ist er dann einfach
leistungsfähiger und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich weh tut
oder verletzt ist einfach wesentlich
geringer okay aber kurz wieder ausloggen
hände aufs kniegelenk kniegelenk kreisen
richtung wechseln oder kurz auslagern
turiner was an so typische aufwärmen
bewegungen die ihr beim badminton spiel
macht also viel beinarbeit ja zeit steps
und tiefen einer weit eben und auch die
schulter okay da fahren wir mit den
beinen an hätte gesagt machen wir mal
einen linien lauf linke grenze recht ist
abgesteckt das heißt dieser schritt
schnell rüber die für schritt und es im
wechsel dzekos gern einfach schnelle
bewegungen und ihr braucht das dann für
die kniebeugen spätestens da muss die
oberschenkelmuskulatur bereit sein und
kurz mit aus lockern ausschüttung sei
nächstes gelenk was ganz wichtig ist
immer wieder mitzunehmen um ihm da keine
verspannungen dann auf ein intensives
wörter zu bekommen ist natürlich die
nackte nacken
die heißere säule dass wir beginnen
wieder mit unserer blick wendung linke
seite rechte seite einfach hin und her
wechseln und nach oben und nach unten
und wir kippen links und rechts sind und
hier die übungen kann es immer mit
einbauen
ja jede minute im büro irgendwo wenn man
merkt es ist ein bisserl es zwickt der
bislang meist verspannt den nacken haben
mobilisieren dann geht es wieder besser
und wir kreisen halbkreise von linken
seite über die brust auf die rechte
seite im wechsel wieder zurück
und wieder kurz aus lockern
was machst du im aufnahmeprozess gerne
der garage mittendrin im harten
körperlichen arbeit aber die idee finde
ich gut wir mal so ihm geht schon los
für euch zu hause
wir fahren mit steam regel stets danach
sieben kniebeugen sie im sit ups und sie
mal den rücken aufrichten zur camerons
muskulär natürlich perfekt vorbereiten
er setzt auch die badminton spieler
wissen wie man liegestütze macht seit
wann geht schon weiter und der wechsel
auf die setups für athletik training
macht ihr beim badminton spielen
wir haben zweimal die woche
krafttraining auch einmal die woche und
dann zusätzlich einfach generell laufen
also doch einige einheiten auch die an
der athletik wo man die athletik
trainiert vom krafttraining etwas
ausdauertraining sprungtraining alles
mit dabei ok mutter nach den vier mal
aufstehen und wenn er das richtige boxer
vorteil den wunsch reaktion auf das
heißt laufen am stand rasches tempo und
wenn von mir als signal kommt runter
einen liegestütz und wieder hoch okay
das heißt auf hopp schnell in die
libysche opposition und wieder hochgeht
schussbereit laufen
[Applaus]
und weiter laufen und das möglichst
rasch möglichst schnell auch nicht
wieder weiterlaufen da kann man
natürlich seine trainingspartner steht
bei mir über das in einer hohen frequenz
macht auslagern lassen wir mal an
durchgang ab und durchschlafen
aber wie gesagt es geht beim aufwärmen
und deswegen weil man es nicht
übertreiben
im zweiten durchgang laufen manchmal
noch als kreislauf system vor ort
richtig an
und das braucht man damit man dann wie
gesagt verletzungsfrei durch das workout
kommen
zweiter durchgang lassen am stand
beschloss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und zeit durchaus locker mal
durchschlafen ja einfach weg sagt jener
vorbereitung muss man gewisse bewegungen
hat einfach immer mit einbauen und das
aktiviert richtig und macht dann bereit
für das nächste was jetzt kommt und das
ist das workout und das erklärte jetzt
ganz kurz wie wir das machen so dass ihr
mit trainieren können wir werden immer
wieder im werk hat drinnen haben eine
gewisse zeit lang laufen
das ist der erste teil des workouts
danach machen wir fünf klimmzüge
liegestütze und das trieb das 15
kniebeugen und wenn ihr diese runde dann
man könnte jetzt noch auf rechnen
20 mal macht zum beispiel dann hätte
meine 100 klimmzüge 200 liegestütze und
307 beieinander
das kriegen wir zeitlich jetzt nicht hin
wir werden unser format durchgänge
beschränken
aber wir fangen wir an mit fünf
spielzügen und sagen jetzt einmal was ja
auch machen können alternativ waren das
nicht ganz funktioniert weil er halt
katja reck oder sonst irgendwas zu hause
habt das heißt erste variante wäre angst
link trainer möglich das heißt wer einen
sling trainer zu hause hat hängt sich da
hinein und sieht sich mit kompakter
position des ausdrücken bauch gespannt
nach vor und wieder zurück dass das ist
einmal eine möglichkeit dem machen kann
die zweite variante ist ihr habt
irgendwie okay die hardcore variante im
sling trainer in die waagrechte nach
oben ziehen
das ist natürlich wesentlich mehr
gewicht und dann was man nach oben
bewegen muss ok zweite variante dritte
variante zeigt wie mancher meinen
rucksack oder ein zusatzgewicht zur hand
so wie du sagst du einmal vor geht's in
die körper vorhalte und sieht das
gewicht richtung brustkorb nach oben das
heißt der satz muskulär auch in dem
bereich wo man beim kind zu kümmern und
so kann sie das ganz gut simulieren wenn
er wie gesagt diese möglichkeit nicht
habt danke schön
und jetzt bitte dafür die noch zum gary
bieten jetzt zeigen wir noch solltet ihr
das die rag haben aber vielleicht noch
keine drei vier oder fünf klimmzüge am
stück schaffen
solche unterstützung nehmt euch ein
gummiband ein resistance band steigt da
rein und macht sie klimmzüge eben mit
unterstützung
durch dieses gummi bundle und dann
funktioniert das auch sehr gut so kann
ich meine wiederholungszahlen nach oben
schrauben und belasten mich körperlich
nicht gleich beim ersten mal im züge
machen so dass sie damit weiter
trainieren kann
so hat er zum schluss der klassische
klimmzug aus der arm streckung mit dem
kino über die brust wieder in die
streckung und wieder nach oben gesetzt
es das funktioniert ganz gut das heißt
die fünf jahre
da brauche ich mir keine sorgen wochen
bei dir gerne wird funktionieren oder
was glaubst normal hinterlässt laut
guest bei klimmzügen 21 klimmzüge es ist
schon mal gar nicht so wenig also das
muss man mal 220 mal das kind über die
stange nach oben ziehen und wieder
komplett in die strecke und nach unten
gehen ok erste übung haben wir den
klimmzug mit unterschiedlichsten
varianten die zweite übung der
liegestütz die übung kemmer bereits aber
noch einmal zur wiederholung er sei in
einer gerade vom sprunggelenk bis zur
schulter geht es runter bis der oberarm
mit der schulter wiederum eine ebene
bildet das heißt dass dort gerade ist
und dann drückt sich wieder hoch der
blick ist in den boden beziehungsweise
leicht nach vorn geneigt das heißt der
kopf ist relativ entspannt
okay da klimmzug in der klassischen
variante zweite variante mit der serena
einfach runter gehen das wird körperlich
muskulär richtig anstrengen
das heißt der künstler gerne am knie
abgestützt machen das ganze oder an der
mauer angelehnt da gibt es
unterschiedlichste varianten wie man ihm
seine liebe zu machen kann
ok danke schön dritte übung kniebeuge
tief kniebeuge natürlich als wunsch
bewegung das heißt zu weit runter wie
möglich wenn das von der beweglichkeit
nicht ganz so gut funktioniert kennt
natürlich auch bei der hälfte oder
irgendwo am weg hat einfach umkehren und
wieder nach oben gehen
je tiefer desto besser achtet auf eure
beinachse achtet auf einen gespannt die
rumpfmuskulatur der rücken der bauch ist
unter spannung und dann kam man
entsprechend intensiv arbeiten da gerne
macht das ganze wie es für den soldaten
gehört mit einem zusatzgewicht mit dem
mit mit dem platten träger quasi mit
einer gewichts weste die hat so ungefähr
zehn kilo
das heißt das kann man sie dann schon
ausrechnen jedes mal der klimmzug mit
zusatzgewicht die liegestützen
kniebeugen
dass sein immer zehn kilo mit mehr dabei
und das ist schon wirklich wirklich cool
und das spürt man noch ganz anders und
noch viel deutlicher dann die belastung
gerne du bist bereit sie mir du bist
bereit
jawohl das ist klassisch militärisch so
erzählt es dann start mann los mit 30
sekunden laufen am stand hohe dynamische
bewegung und danach gemeinde klimmzüge
hinein geht schon los
und wie gesagt auch das laufen ist mit
zusatzgewicht gar nicht so ohne das tut
man nur dann trainieren wenn man
wirklich das oft macht die beinachse
stabil hat und lauftechnik keine
probleme keine lernfelder da sind dann
macht man sie mit zusatzgewicht
beziehungsweise auch alternativ übung
dann trage ich mag an der ruhig zwischen
trainer kurze pause machen fünf
triebzüge für ihn auch gegenseitig
natürlich als partner werk hat man
unterstützt sich gegenseitig dann hat er
an immer kurze pause
da andere arbeitet es geht jetzt nicht
darum dass wir dieses werk hat jede
übung ohne irgendein sekunde
durchschnaufen durchzieht sondern
einfach einmal das kennen lernt und
merkt was für große körperliche
belastung damit dabei liegestütz zehn
stück mit gewichts weste und ohne
sehr gut
serena ist auch fertig zehn liegestütze
erledigt und dann gleich in die
kniebeuge 50 stück tiefer geht's los
achtet auf eure beinachse achtet auf
einen stabilen muskulär gesicherten ruf
und die tiefe gestaltet er je nachdem
wie eure beweglichkeit im ausschaut 15
wiederholungen laufen am stand geht
schon los
das ist der letzte teil der bewegung das
heißt auf die kniebeugen wo der
oberschenkel schon vorbelastet ist muss
man danach in real noch eine weile
laufen in unserem fall am stand laufen
das heißt ihr merkt schon den wechsel
zwischen der kraft belastung und jetzt
der ausdauerbelastung das spürt man in
den beinen schon sehr deutlich sekunden
und kurz auslagern
okay manchmal kurz serien pause schluck
trinken haben wir durch schlafen und
dann legen wir wieder los wieder mit dem
ersten teil der bewegung das heißt
wieder kurzes laufen und auf das laufen
gleich wieder die klimmzüge liegestütze
und kniebeugen die varianten also die da
abläuft bleibt immer das selbe 30
konnten 30 sekunden laufen geht schon
los
und das ist ja die hohe kunst bei dieser
challenge das herz kreislauf system geht
über das laufen massiv nach oben und
dann eine kraft belastung draufsetzen
ist richtig richtig intensiv und
anstrengend und wenn ihr das gesamtpaket
der wirtschaft der ehemals in kleine
teilschritte so wie wir das machen und
versucht das ganze so zu machen noch
fünf sekunden sei das und dem zu gehen
1 2 3 4 und 5 sehr gut hinein hängen und
geht schon los
12 35 und wir wechseln wäre auf die
dicke stetig sagt weniger erholungsphase
für muskel gleich den wechsel zehn
liegestütze mit voller körperspannung
das knie gestreckt property fund
arbeiten wert durch ist mit den
liegestütz kann natürlich sofort in die
knie beugen gehen 15 wiederholungen
ungefähr halbzeit
tief runter gehen und 15 wiederholungen
haben wir wieder erledigt
wir laufen wieder jetzt schloss aus dass
beim laufen die belastung ab diese steht
uns das denn aus der muskulatur oder er
macht das so wie die jury die gibt beim
laufen habe ziemlich gas also
anscheinend ist das badminton training
doch nicht so unähnlich dem militärisch
wie das weitergeht richtig was wir
machen nur zehn sekunden noch 521 und
kultur schlafen ist laut schütteln und
dann legen wir schon wieder los und
gehen wir wieder übers laufen in die
klimmzüge liegestütze in die kniebeuge
zum laufen wir lassen die reihenfolge
muss man gleich bereit dann laufen los
kurz durchschnaufen kurze pause und dann
geht schon wieder los
so ärgert kann natürlich jederzeit im
park draußen machen am spielplatz wo es
entsprechend arek gibt zum hochziehen
also da gibt es unterschiedlichste
möglichkeiten da kann ich mir wirklich
draußen nimmt sich das handy mit dem 16
das video mit schlecht erst dann an wenn
jetzt mit uns im nachhinein draußen das
ist eine gute variante um der
entsprechende an der frischen luft was
zu machen
nach 10 5
21 uhr wechsel kurz durchschnaufen und
cellos alternative einen rucksack sent
back ein zusatzgewicht geraderücken
vorhalte und zur brust sind
soweit fertig um vor allem richtung
erdmittelpunkt immer so schön sagt und
zehn wiederholungen liegestütz da war
volle beuge volle strecke wirklich
technisch immer sauber arbeiten
[Applaus]
aufstehen und kniebeugen schloss braucht
es nicht aufeinander warten und synchron
arbeiten das ist nicht notwendig genau
wie vor unter mit dem gesäß dynamisch
hochkommen muskulär abgesicherter
oberkörper das sind die dinge auf das
achtet neben einer stabilen beinachse
und zeit arbeiten 15 wiederholungen
jetzt war es durch
[Applaus]
noch sind sie konnten
und kurz ausschlafen kurz aus lockern
ich glaube jetzt aber durch irgendein x
2 oder also zwei wochen noch geht's los
für euch zu hause dann haben wir vier
durchgänge 20 km züge das heißt auf 50
von der gesamtbelastung hält man dann in
summe abgearbeitet dass der ungefähre
einrichten kennt wie hoch die belastung
über die gesamte dauer über die 100
klimmzüge 200 liegestütze und 300
kniebeugen ist auf fünf gesagt haben wir
nach zwei durchgängen schafft dann würde
ich vorschlagen
wenn man jetzt langsam an heißen brei
herum stadtwerke wieder 30 sekunden
bewegen auch hier kann es natürlich mit
der dynamik knie heben angst wie es mit
einbauen um es euch entsprechend
schwierig zu machen oder auch die zeit
nutzen um das system aber zum
runterfahren ein bisschen zu
regenerieren zwischendrin zwischen den
graf belastungen
beide varianten eben möglich nach 30
runden sei es durch ausschütteln
klimmzüge gemacht wieder klassisch ohne
unterstützung mit gerichtsfeste serena
mit dem resistent band so das ist jetzt
kamera machen mit jedem hilfsmittel was
man zuhause findet
ok 5 wieder fünf wiederholungen erledigt
libysche darstellung sehen
wiederholungen und geht's los
auch hier acht jetzt immer wieder
kontrolliert sich immer wieder wie ist
die position von meinem kopf wie tief
geht runter wie hoch komme ich auf wie
gestreckt sind meine beine
diese dinge berücksichtigen immer bei
jeder einzelnen runde
wir beiden gewinner wie gäste bei den
liegestützen verhältnis zu den
kniebeugen merkt man den unterschied von
ja also beim badminton glaube ist
kniebeugen eine bewegung ist immer
machst oder und den links nicht ganz so
häufig anstrengend aber das ist auch gut
so wir werden dann zum schluss die
schulter aus locker und natürlich
spannungen wieder herausnehmen so dass
du in die nächste trainingseinheit
einfach eine staaten kannst dann ok dann
lasst mal kurz wieder da doch
tempowechseln hohes tempo niedriges
tempo variiert zur bisserl das nicht
monoton nicht eintönig wird das ganze 15
sekunden noch 10
[Applaus]
kurz starb kurz auslaufen wie gesagt
jedes jederzeit einfach ein schluck
trinken wenn es notwendig ist und
entsprechend vorbereiten auf die nächste
runde und die runde startet im zugeht
schloss und 5 variante machst du wieder
extremen sehr gut
wichtig ist dass wir mit spannung
erwartet und entsprechend den oberkörper
da hochzieht sowie macht es sehr gut
und gleich wieder wechseln und
liegestütze tief runter und wieder
komplett in die streckung nach oben aber
die beine jetzt geschlossen habe so der
geöffnet habt macht für die kraft aus
dem oberarm nicht wirklich einen
unterschied bereits machen für die
beiden 15 wiederholungen oberkörper
aufrecht stolzer brust
berger und den letzten durchgang eins
machen braucht man ohne bewegung hätte
gesagt schauen wir dass wir noch eine
doppelte belastung in die muskulatur
einbringen das heißt es laufen lassen
wir es weg und gehen gleich nochmal im
zuge hinein
das geht ja fast easy durchschlafen
bereitmachen konzentrieren zehn
liegestütze
das tempo gestaltet sie nimmt sich zeit
für eine technisch saubere ausführung
und 15 kniebeugen letztes mal kraft
belasten in diesen durchgängen und dann
haben wir wie gesagt auf 50 vom gesamten
worth up trainiert gemeinsam trainiert
und wie gesagt die die lust haben können
natürlich gleich weiter trainieren und
schauen wie lange sie das tempo auch
durchhalten
ok lockert haben einmal erledigt
datenträger die nicht erst einmal
herunter geben ein bisschen aus lockern
ausgehen ausschied und die gelenke
muskulatur aus bewegen den as rom war
schon intensiv war schon sehr hoch und
dann müssen wir dem körper die
möglichkeit geben wieder kontrolliert
das system wieder nach unten zu fahren
und diese belastung ab bis du wieder
rauszukriegen
und da fangen wir am besten mit einer
übung serena noch ein horten intensiven
training was machst du gerne also auf
denen mit zu viel
das was sich da nicht okay ganz locker
bisserl denen ihnen die position der
beim workout genau da ist das und die
oberarme genauso und da wäre nicht so
schlecht wenn man auch schauen dass man
eventuell bislang zug wieder
herausbringen wie gesagt ganz wichtig
nach einer intensiven belastung nur ganz
nieder intensiver bisserl in die
spannung hineingehen um den muskel
wieder in eine normale länge vielleicht
zu bringen aber jetzt definitiv kd
worker draus machen bei der es belastet
das system dann doppelt und da passieren
dann verletzungen seite wechseln
und immer wieder weiteratmen
durchschnaufen
genau 18 sekunden und aber wieder
abschütteln aus lockern welche übung
macht sie für die schulter zum amt für
die seele da vielleicht so nach hinten
ausmachen okay dann haben also einen
vorderen anteil der shooter mit
autorinnen
genau das ist andy hinten zusammen und
so weit wie es geht nach oben strecken
dabei aufrecht bleiben stolzer brust
lassen nicht ein kippen nicht einfahren
jetzt da alles anstrengend war sondern
wirklich schönen einspannen
ok dann mal wieder plant druck heraus
wäre was machst du zum gutenberg schwung
gymnastik dann macht man mal bei übungen
schwung gymnastik dazu das ist ganz
einfach an meinem stand die hände voran
zurückfallen lassen
entsprechende mittel dazu bewegen so wie
man es von den zwei schwimmerinnen
bereits mit kriegt keiner hin stehen in
eine oberkörper vorbeuge und
entsprechend die hände voran
zurückfallen lassen
okay was man auch was man auch der boxer
zum regenerieren dann niemals gänge java
nachdem man eine hohe belastung in den
unterarm drin gehabt haben vom greifen
vom eigenen gewicht halten bei den
klimmzüge oder auch bei den alternativ
übungen fingerspitze schauen zurück
ellbogengelenk ist gestreckt und dann
geht es einmal ein stickel zurück so
dass ein zug im unterarm hinein bekommt
die position hier so nett schmerzhaft
sein sondern einfach nur die spannung
heraus
dann drehen wir das ganze um das heißt
wir gehen einmal auf den handrücken nun
hat die zweite seite nur dazu auch hier
ellbogen schön strecken und so weit wie
es geht zurückgehen und die position
halten oder ganz locker deshalb bewegen
beide varianten sind möglich gesagt
nicht in eine endgültige bewegung da
hineingehen sondern ganz locker
und da mehr ausschütten stehen wir noch
mal auf was gibst du unseren zuschauern
zu hause damit wie heute man sich am
besten fit also ich denke am wichtigsten
ist es dass man übungen aussucht die
einem spaß machen weil dann also dann
macht man es einfach gerne und man tut
dann auch regelmäßig also das heißt dass
spaß und der übung muss dabei sein man
muss das gerne machen dann macht man es
regelmäßig da haben wir die
regelmäßigkeit wieder mit drinnen die
ganz ganz wichtig ist um ähnlich sagt
einen leistungsausbau auch zu haben ok
ich sage danke dir danke serena fürs mit
trainieren
danke dass ihr mit dabei was das war wie
gesagt die dreißigste ausgabe works
challenge und wir freuen uns auf ein
mögliches nächstes training